I'm glad that they're doing the payouts
even though man I look at some people
they're just like buying cars with their
payouts I'm making pennies over here I
could barely afford a quar pound of a
cheese with my payouts but it's okay
it's great are you getting can have you
said publicly I haven't but I'll break
it here this is breaking news I hope all
the journalists start writing it up uh
my first payout was right when I signed
up was like8 or 900 bucks and then it
dropped to like 200 bucks and that's
like a hundred bucks but I'm getting
more impressions it's not impression
based it okay yeah the the money you get
from X is based on how many verified
users interact with your posts this is
why you're seeing tons of people ask
questions so this is the thing cuz I
don't I don't engagement bait you know I
just kind of sometimes I do accidentally
because people don't like my opinions
but I don't I you're right the people
who are getting zillion dollar payouts
they all post things like you know do
you hate peanut butter and jelly why